- That girl's like,
"You look cool."
I was like "Thanks."
You see that?
Yeah it was funny.
- [DRock] You look cool.
- I'm much cooler with my hat,
I definitely do believe that.
("Unstoppable" by This Is Wolff)
("Impossible" by Lucien Parker)
- [Gary] That's what's
gonna end up happening.
That's what's
happening now, Steph.
That's what DailyVee and
#AskGaryVee is about right?
Like I've been so
right historically,
like now I'm just not
gonna leave any debate for it.
Or lost in history or
me having to say I said so.
Like it's just
gonna be there right?
There's also, let me
add it here actually 'cause
this is a very smart
statement for business people.
The other thing that
Musical.ly should consider,
or should be
considering right now,
is the fact that Facebook,
the fact that
Facebook successfully pivoted,
to being a
mobile-first platform years ago,
is the biggest reason
it's a winning company today.
Tumblr and Pinterest,
leaders
in the 2011, '12, '13 world,
were unable to become as
dominant in mobile which opened
the door for
Instagram and Snapchat.
And so what Musical.ly
may be able to do
is become a disproportionate
leader in something like voice,
in something like I can't
even think of right now,
that is a platform shift.
And so, some great
move, some big change that
that changes the paradigm for
them, that you need to make
those big moves at
times to find opportunity.
And right now, as of
the writing of this book,
I think they need something big
to gain momentum, especially
in that 12 to 17 year old crowd,
to start growing
into that area deeper.
The only thing you're
risking by taking these leaps
is your time.
The upside of being
right about one of the pillar
social networks and being a
first mover is life changing.
The downside is
you "wasted time",
and who are you to be
so fancy about your time.
That's the punchline
Steph everybody's so fucking,
like all these
people that wanna break out,
all these people
that wanna live the life,
that want all this
great shit to happen
Steph, they're not willing to
"risk their time" for that
upside in case it's Myspace,
or Vine instead of
Facebook or Instagram,
who the fuck are they?
Like you're a beggar,
you don't get to choose.
Right?!
You're a fucking beggar,
you like want to not be
an accountant anymore, you
wanna be America's beekeeper.
So you're telling me that
you're not "willing to take the"
like you're willing to
write off Musical.ly right now
while you're
reading this, fuck you.
("Impossible" by Lucien Parker)
Landed in Montreal this
morning from the red eye,
got a couple hours of
sleep, got a nice little
gym session in with Jordan.
And then was upstairs,
did a bunch of business calls.
All good stuff.
Some cool new
Facebook commercials
coming out of VaynerMedia
that I'm gonna
be proud of I hope.
And then, hey, I'll be with
ya in one sec don't worry.
And then, come
on in don't worry.
We keep it very,
don't worry, we keep,
And then had a nice two hour
session with Stephanie Land,
my ghostwriter, we're
finishing up Crushed It.
Which will come out in
January it looks like of '18,
so I'm excited
about that, the follow up
to the book that
kinda put me on the map.
And now I'm in the
green room about to
rip everybody's fucking
faces off here in Montreal.
And that's that.
- [Man 1] In the flesh.
- In the real flesh.
- [Man b1] In the real
freaking flesh. My man.
- [Gary] How you doin'? Good?
- I'm great, man.
- Good. Glad to hear.
- [Man 1] I'm excited
for your sports brand there.
- Oh yeah, we're
excited about it, man.
- There's Samuel
Dallinmer here too.
- He's a player.
- Yeah. Came to support
his friends so, awesome, man.
I know you're
going to be busy so--
- You want to
sneak it in now?
(both laughing)
I love it.
- [Man 1] We'll meet you after.
I can't wait.
Sure, of course.
- Thank you, man.
- You got it.
You're welcome.
I'll be set.
- [Man 2] Here's your coffee.
- Thank you, brother.
- [Man 2] You're welcome.
("Tuesday" by JMKM)
- Hey.
- [Gary] 'Sup, bro?
- Thanks for that title
on Twitter yesterday.
- Yeah.
- Can you give me advice how to
make my business I'm starting to
go full time?
'Cause I really wanna become
a copywriter full time with a
specific niche.
I also want to write
book as a living without
working that 9 to 5.
- [Gary] It's by eating shit up
front so that you can win later.
- [Man 3] Yeah.
- I mean it's like what you
gonna do at midnight tonight?
- [Man b3] Yeah.
I always do it after
school and after--
- It's just getting exposure.
It's about getting exposure.
It's posting on
Medium, LinkedIn,
you own blog, Facebook
I think's an incredible
place to write copy.
- Yeah.
- So it's just hacking.
- [Man 3] Yeah.
- It's like how
do I get muscles?
You work out every day.
- [Man 3] You work
out every day, yeah.
Yeah.
- Got it?
- [Man 3] Yeah, for sure.
- Alright, brother.
- Thanks, man.
- Take care.
But it looks great.
And it's a worthwhile attempt
but the truth is my opinion,
other people's opinion,
it's all execution.
- Yeah.
- Facebook 90% people
thought was stupid.
Snapchat 90% of the
people thought it was stupid.
Twitter 99% of the
Regardless of what
any of us think,
you got to get
this out and react to
what people react to it.
- [Man 4] Awesome.
- Thank you for the book.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] Thank you, brother.
- I see all The
#AskGaryVee Shows.
- [Gary] Thank you.
- I look up to you.
- [Gary] Thank you, brother.
- My name's Fabrice.
I run a non-profit
called Pour 3 Points.
Yeah we train sports cultures so
that these cultures become sort
of life cultures for youth in
low income schools of Montreal.
- Understood.
- I look up to guys like
Scott Harrison, Adam Braun.
- Yes, yes, I know
them quite very well.
- Yeah, exactly.
My question is what makes
you invest and support social
entrepreneurs like these guys?
Not you personally but I want
to get into your mind about why
you'd do it?
- I'll tell you.
Because I don't think
they're full of shit.
I think they're 100 percent
honest about the fact that they
want to do good.
- Yeah.
- But they don't disguise
that they care about
themselves, too.
- Got it.
- So I hate when people try
to be altruistic and be like,
"I want to save the world."
No, you don't.
- Got it.
- Got it?
- Of course, I got it.
- That's it.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, cool.
- [Gary] Yeah, I mean
that's a good point.
I mean look but also as you know
what made you so successful on
the field, was when nobody
was watching off the field.
Right?
So you're talking
about the game.
I get tapped and feedback,
when I go on stage right now,
I'm gonna get feedback.
So, you see where I'm going?
I know what you did in the
weight room and what you were
doing when nobody was watching.
And I think that's
what entrepreneurship is.
I get all this a little bit.
My normal 18 hours is what I was
doing in the hotel room for the
last five hours,
putting out fires,
making business deals,
running an organization.
So I do think
there's similarities.
- I love it.
- [Gary] I think it's somebody
who disproportionately brings
value to other people which
then allows them to have those
people's attention and I think
the best purebred influencers
know what to do
with that attention.
My biggest concern is that
there's a lot of influencers who
are doing a lot of selfish
behavior with their attention.
It's all about themselves
and I think that that will
ultimately play itself out
and give them a short run.
But for me the ultimate
influencer is a guy or a gal
that understands that to
get people to care about you
forever, you've got to
disproportionately bring them
more value than you're
asking for in return.
Good energy here in Montreal
a lot of influencers,
influencer marketing,
everybody wants to be an
influencer before they actually
do the thing that
gives them the influence.
That's the issue
so just gonna make
sure I drill it home
to this audience of like
work, skills, craft, value...
patience.
It's a nice concoction
of needs and
everybody's attacking it with
fluff tactics,
tricks, shortcuts.
selfishness, impatience.
It's why 99% of
people don't have
extraordinary outcomes.
Not super complicated.
Math has made it pretty easy.
DailyVee, 1994
to 2013 is what...
got me to this, you know?
- [Man 5] We're
going on soon, now.
Like one minute, okay?
- Let's go, Gary!
- [Gary] 'Sup man?
Good to see you.
(speaking in a foreign language)
- [Man 6] Are we
excited or what?
(audience cheers and applause)
Without further ado,
I'm going to go quiet,
and I'm going to let
an international speaker.
Guys, make some
noise for GaryVee!
(audience cheers)
("Public Service
Announcement" by Jay Z)
- Thank you.
Thank you.
Appreciate it.
That was nice.
(audience laughing)
It's interesting to me that,
what continues to
run through my mind,
is that the words
mean absolute zero,
and that the
actions mean everything.
That the scariest thing for me
is that there are
hundreds of millions of people
who have the word
entrepreneur and influencer
in their Instagram account
and think that
means they are one.
(audience laughter and applause)
Glad some people are
clapping that shit up,
because that's the truth.
Because what's
happening in our space,
and it's amazing to have
professional athletes here,
is that's like me
saying basketball player
and writing it in
my Instagram profile.
I play basketball,
I don't get paid
to play basketball.
("Drink a Lil" by Marion Write)
Don't ask me ever again how
to run Facebook ads,
or do Instagram
influencer campaign,
or create a Snapchat filter,
or how to start a podcast.
The information is
free, at your fingertip,
and if you are not savvy enough,
or willing to put in the work,
to be able to do a
Google search and consume it,
you might as well leave
this fucking room right now.
(audience applause)
So she basically, again,
it's a little hard to hear.
She's basically
asking "How do you compete
"when the people
you're competing with
"have a ton of
money and you don't?"
You have no choice.
Basically.
(audience laughter)
- We'll take another question.
- Now, now that I've done my
dramatic pause, let me explain.
(audience laughter)
That question always fucks
with me because, guess what?
Apple was small as shit, too.
Like, every brand and business
and person that
ever won, was zero.
So, it's execution.
My best work is when
I have limited resources.
I was at my best
in early Wine Library.
I wish I was doing fucking
DailyVee as a 22-year-old
with Wine Library,
because then none of
you would have any excuses.
I had $14,000 to spend
for the year in marketing,
after I sold a
bunch of wine to people
to be able to even have that.
Which meant I just
stood in the liquor store
for 15 hours a day,
and people would walk in
wanting to buy
one bottle of wine,
and I hustled them for three.
Like it was just grinding.
I never fucking Instagrammed
and get a lucky hashtag.
(audience laughter)
So, sorry.
So, you know,
when I was doing e-mail
when nobody was doing it.
Like, when you
have nothing, or little,
you're at your best,
'cause you have no choice.
When you have money,
you get lazy and fat.
(audience laughs)
Montreal, I gotta go.
I can not miss this flight.
(audience applause)
But I think
I've changed my mind.
I think I changed my mind!
I love Montreal now!
(audience cheers)
("Drink a Lil" by Marion Write)
Become a Jet.
And you need to
take advantage of that!
And there's millions
of people like that.
So for me,
they've all the advantages
of all the relationships.
And then the same
thing that got them
to the highest level of sports
is all the hard work.
It's just hard work.
Like, all this was hard work.
This is a manifestation of
I've been working
since I was 14 years old.
Every fucking day.
You know what I mean?
This is 27 years in the making.
27 years in the making.
And I don't think
people understand that.
Super successful week.
Intense.
San Francisco.
Chicago.
Kansas City.
Kansas City to
Detroit to Columbus, Ohio.
Columbus, Ohio
to Dallas to Vegas.
Red eye from Vegas to Montreal.
Now all wrapping up late
night Friday to New York City.
Jordan's got his eyes closed.
- [Jordan] No, I don't.
- [Gary] Yeah you did.
I just looked at you.
Don't lie.
(Jordan laughs)
Jordan's lying.
You know, it's how
we do it around here.
- Thank you.
- Thank you my friend.
Take care of yourself.
- [Man 6] All the best.
- [Gary] Thank you so much,
thank you, my friend.
Alright so I'm heading into
the airport here in Montreal.
We've had a big breakthrough,
DRock and I just had a moment.
If you follow me on Snapchat
stories and Instagram stories,
you can see that I really just
had the breakthrough moment
on the audio experience,
the GaryVee Audio Experience
which is every day,
we're filming all day.
And there's gold,
original content
that can be used
for the audio
experience in the podcast.
But we're editing with
only the intent for the vlog,
so I just told DRock,
that's it, everyday
you, Tyler,
Justin, whoever, Iris,
we're gonna find good chunks
where we may use a minute of it.
But in nine minutes
and 13 seconds form
in its complete thought,
it can be an incredible
original piece of content
to the audio experience.
So, that's what we're
doing today in Montreal,
kind of like flew in,
gave a keynote
around influencer marketing.
But what I really
wanted to focus on
in this episode
of the podcast is
I spent an hour
and a half, two hours,
with Stephanie Land,
my ghostwriter.
And we started creating,
we're on third base on
our next book, "Crushed It."
Which is the follow-up
to the breakthrough book
"Crush It!" of my career.
The updated version of what
to do on all these platforms.
And that's what
we focused on today.
And so we're listening
to now is some raw footage
of the behind-the-scenes
that will
manifest in January 2018's
New York Times
Bestselling book, "Crushed It".
- [DRock] You
wanna give me a bite?
- Yeah, I'm outta here.
See ya, Montreal.
Beautiful day,
beautiful time, missed you,
haven't been here a whole bunch.
Toronto and Vancouver
have been getting more
of the Canadian love.
But I enjoyed my time.
Thought the keynote was good.
I thought Jordan was okay.
DRock was solid.
I was phenomenal.
("Drink a Lil" by Marion Write)